he's saying give him hell and he says I
need you to find me 80 Jewish families
and then you had uh Omar suan stepping
up and telling him to go to hell so that
we're willing to volunteer to move to
Jerusalem so we can reestablish a Jewish
presence in this city to see someone
like
omaran the stuff that's left out of your
history book when Palestine is free
people like him are going to be ashamed
that they did this this guy right here
this guy's trying to build a DA Center
in our country I'm not talking right now
you're AO you're trying to build a dawa
Center here Islam is violent by Nature
asalam brothers and sisters this is
exactly why we need the dean Center
because we have over 300 million
Americans who know nothing about Islam
like this guy hey you want to have a
talk yeah this guy's trying to build a
DA Center in our country and Surah 9 is
the most violent chapter of the Quran
the dean Center will be a source of
light a mega dawa Center an educational
center helping our brothers and sisters
in humanity truly understand Islam and
Muslims and brothers and sisters
remember the great rewards of just
guiding one person in humanity to the
truth is better than everything in this
dun so get in on all the rewards and
blessings click the link below donate
right now may God Almighty Allah reward
all of
[Music]
you asalam Alum greens of Peace welcome
to the D your host subscribe if you
haven't already hit that notification
Bell woke up this morning and you saw
that there was a state of war and we
wanted to go ahead and shed some um
light on more of the context of the
relationship between Islam Muslims and
Jews and with me here is she Yousef how
are
you yourself good good alhamdulillah
it's good to see you you too as well uh
we had um very interesting uh some very
uh interesting developments and again
disclaimer is very sad anytime you know
innocent life is taken um human life is
precious life and uh we like nothing
more than to have peace with uh all of
our neighbors uh what do you think about
that of course that that's that's an
Islamic concept um uh Community cohesion
uh living together coexisting living
side by side helping one another uh in
that which we uh uh have common ground
on is is definitely these are all
Islamic uh values that we uphold and and
and live for it and stand by in the
midst of all this you have Jordan
Peterson Peterson who the last time when
we met actually uh we were actually
praising Jordan Peterson you remember
and now he actually uh tweeted and we'll
go through some of these tweets uh he's
he's saying give him hell he's talking
uh enough is enough and we're not going
to get into uh some details specifics
here but just generally uh some generals
here that we'll be discussing so and
then you had uh Omar sulan stepping up
and telling him to go to hell so it was
uh I didn't know he had him in he is
nice to see I'm quite surprised uh and
yeah it's it's um I mean let me get let
me get through these hold on so we got
our brother uh shik Omar suan stepping
up and telling Jordan Peterson to go to
hell Subhan Allah uh and then you have
uh and these are all under the tweets
under there Daniel steps in he says how
does it feel he's talking to Jordan
Peterson to be a cheap prostitute he's
talking to um to Jordan Peterson you
have Samir Khan owned she says own you
have aliren I had recently on the
program he's he's telling Jordan
Peterson and you can see a lot of
Muslims actually respected Jordan
Peterson right and you were one of those
for the right for the right reasons yeah
and then he says uh when I watched uh
Jordan Peterson being played on daily
Wire by little Ben and Netanyahu I
thought he would be intelligent enough
to figure out that he was being played
but I guess the benzos the money has
done their damage and you got Robert
Carter saying yeah that's it Peterson
earn your new paycheck you little ho he
wow Bo oh so um it hasn't been taken
down uh I don't that's allowed on
Twitter yeah uh so uh your thoughts when
you uh when you see this obviously
there's a it's a declaration of war
right now there's with Israel we've seen
operations and whatnot but now it's uh I
guess it's it's you know this this this
this nonsense this this oppression
that's been happening to the Palestinian
people for decades now if if not more um
is is something that obviously is is
and it's very sad to see that the
American people have not woken up to
this yet alhamdulillah by the by the
grace of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala and
the means of social media uh YouTube and
these you know uh uh smartphones and so
on and so forth I think a lot of people
have somewhat more access definitely
more than than before because before
you'd only get the standard narrative
that you're going to get from that part
of the world regarding as to what's
happening between the Israeli
Palestinian conflict as they'd like to
put when in reality it's it's not the
Israeli uh Israeli Palestinian conflict
it's the oppression the Injustice the
ongoing
injustices that keep perpetuating
against the Palestinian people I mean
this is literally an apart hide that's
existed and Trans transpiring in the
21st century in
2023 this is happening where people are
not allowed right to even access to
basic necessities and the average
American I think is simply not aware as
to what is going on and what has been
taking place in that part of the world a
lot of people think oh it's just these
crazy nutcase Palestinians who have
absolutely nothing to do than to roam
the streets and to cause havoc and to
cause damage right to the to to to the
Jewish people that that's not what's
happening over there I want to get your
reaction to this and this is what uh
probably got a lot of a lot of people
upset with Jordan Peterson if he's
trying to really be a man of peace or
someone promoting peace doesn't seem
like it why wouldn't he try to you know
this is self-evident it's something that
you you you look at I've had M PID he's
uh wrote in a book The General son I
don't know if you got a chance to see
that he's an Israeli Jew he's someone
who's putting his neck on the line
coming out and speaking against these
injustices that are happening when
Palestine is free people like him are
going to be ashamed that they did this
he's going to be embarrassed that he did
this you know there's a famous Rabbi who
lived in Jerusalem he was one of the
anti-zionist rabbis
like like Rabbi Weiss that you
interviewed and he was interviewed by a
student of his and the student said to
him if um uh if you were in charge today
what would be the first thing that you
would do and this Rabbi said the first
thing I would do is I would ask the
Palestinians to come back and the
student says why what are you talking
about they're terrorists they want to
kill us and the rabbi his name is Rabbi
amam Rabbi amram Blau and the rabbi said
who told you that who told you that the
Arabs were going to kill us we had great
relations with the Muslims and the Arabs
back in the day you know his family
lived in Hebron and his half family
lived in Jerusalem that always had you
know Jewish minorities he said we had
great relations we shared the same
values we shared the similar culture you
know we all treated each other with
respect it was only only when the
zionists
came the beginning of the 20th century
that the terrorism began that the
violence began and it was initiated not
by the Palestinians not by the Arabs and
the Muslims but by the zionists you know
open air prism basic you know on one
side you got people full running water
electricity all day imagine you now
you're on the other side and only for a
fraction of the time maybe two 5% of the
time you get that running water you get
dirty water you get electricity 247 on
one side across the street on the other
side of the fence you got it for only
you know a fraction of the time maybe
one one few hours a week or something
right so basic you know human life is
not being put kids are being um uh
thrown in jail jail you got the babies
being killed you got
all and these are people credible people
you got Rabbi Weiss have had him on the
show that Palestine has the right to be
free and that is unacceptable to occupy
Palestine it is unacceptable what these
zionists are doing so it's not the thing
is it's not like a Jew Muslim thing and
I and that's why I wanted you to react
to this this next one this is a
university Professor it's one thing us
talking about this history but we're
going to show here because that's the
greater schem of thing if Jordan Peter
sees this he can he could actually do
some good he can call people to to to to
Really you know come into the past
present and try to uh do some good with
that platform instead of you know what's
he saying just go go go get them
indiscriminate we know what happens when
then you have indiscriminate killing
bombing of civilians who can't get out
like you know I want to make this very
clear our stance is the prophet Muhammad
stance that you know I'm putting this
Hadith on the wall do not kill in any
child woman elderly
you know the practice of treachery you
know uting treat this is like the
Commandments of War this is pretty
straight you know killing one innocent
child non-combatant is as you kill the
world so this is our stand this is you
know we love nothing more of Peace but
just giving the the greater contest of
things here let's get into this video
and get your um your take on this so
people can see the history of how
Muslims have really been towards Jewish
people and this is not a Muslim Jewish
this is this is when you have the
zionists who are taking charge good good
differentiation
yeah okay so the context here we'll just
play a clip is now Muslims came and
conquered Jerusalem Omar uh head of
state he conquers now and they had done
you know all sorts of you know uh
treachery and whatnot now he his chanes
to take revenge right but he didn't and
he did the same thing Prophet Muhammad
did when he came in 10,000 strong to
Mecca and he ended up showing Mercy
spread the peace spread the food he's
following the example of prophet
Muhammad after that salahudin know UB
would do the same thing we're making it
short and concise people go check this
history out you don't get to learn this
usually in school this professor is
teaching this history in school now he's
getting to the point where Omar he's
saying like where the Jews and watch
what happens next at that point Theif
says I want to see the temple
Mount and coronius goes why and KH goes
because it's holy it's holy to everybody
it's holy to Christian it's holy to Jews
it's holy to Muslims and sephius goes
nah we haven't been treating it as holy
to
anybody and omab goes what do you
mean and so seonia says so after we tore
down the second temple of Solomon when
we conquered
Palestine we turned the Temple Mount
into a garbage jump to punish the
Jews and so and the khif goes what do
you
mean and so fonus goes yeah we've been
there's like 500 years of refu on that
thing it's just a garbage
dump and he goes show me they walk up to
the Temple Mount and the can't believe
what he's looking at he falls on his
knees and he begins clearing the garbage
by his hands his army sees their leader
on his knees clearing garbage and they
run up and they start clearing the
garbage
themselves and they clear the garbage
off the Temple
mount the khif goes
okay I want to meet some of the Jews
living in Jerusalem and sophronius goes
there are no Jews in
Jerusalem and the KH goes what do you
mean there's no Jews in Jerusalem the
city is Holy to the Jews how could there
be no Jews and he says well us
Christians we pretty much murder them
every chance we get we really hate Jews
in fact in the war we just did against
the Persians the Jews sided with the
Persians and so we murdered 20,000 Jews
in Jerusalem and completely purged the
city of its remaining Jewish
population and Omar goes no this is
wrong you can't do
this and so he turns to a convert to
Islam a Jewish convert to Islam
and he says I need you to find me 80
Jewish
families that were willing to volunteer
to move to Jerusalem so we can
reestablish a Jewish presence in the
city and
that's how the Muslims conquered
Jerusalem and that's the stuff that's
left out of your history book isn't that
crazy because isn't that an amazing
story that's the stuff that's left out
of your history books if we would have
just talked about is one thing but now
you have an academic this a Prof we know
this history right uh but this is the
stuff they're leaving out of the history
books intentionally so why would if if
Muslims hated
Jews why would they want to Omar he's
repop there's no no I mean do they
understand that this is like no Jews in
Jerusalem they're gone they've been
being killed you know the Christian are
killing them and he's like where they at
he's showing looking for the Temple
Mount it's covered what with garbage how
many hundreds of years
it and then he bili to repopulate
Jerusalem look at the he even the look
at that yeah yeah so are they your enemy
because of that no I I think we have as
you mentioned earlier I think there's
the benchmarker I think the
differentiating factor is are we talking
about
zionists zionists here or or are we
speaking of of Jews and Christians I
think there's there's there's a big I
mean you have many Jews Jewish right
just so I'm not accused of being an
anti-semite because today if you
criticize just by criticizing uh uh not
Judaism but you know Zionism and what
the state of Israel is doing you're
immediately deemed an anti-semite right
it's as if there's absolutely no room
for legitimate criticism that's just but
a you know polyan that's just polyanic
Dre daydreaming you cannot criticize uh
uh what they're doing right there's no
room for that absolutely zip zil not a
cintilla right unfortunately and this
what makes you know things you know
exacer Ates the matter even more so the
problem is not necessarily having an
issue with them oh because they're
Christian or because they're Jews we
have many even during the the the the
even during the the high time or the
Golden Age of Islam you had it's not
like it's a fantasy Community cohesion
in coexistence it's not a fantasy people
talk about it like it's a fantasy as
though it never existed in history
before yet Muslims living next to
Christians Christians living next to
Jews Jews living next to Muslims and
certain Jews actually occupy certain you
know certain positions even in the
Islamic government right um so it's not
our our beef here is not necessarily
with oh because they're Jews or because
they're Christians I mean we as Muslims
were were obviously allowed to marry
Jewish women men are allowed to marry
Christian women so if the beef was
necessarily with Jews or Christians then
Muslim men would not be allowed to marry
Jewish women or Christian women but the
beef is not necessarily there mhm yeah
uh you and you know you make you make me
think of something else here I think we
as Americans I think we really have to
move Beyond this idea I mean it at first
I think it was we can we could get away
with being gullible naive unaware and
ignorant of what is taking place in the
world but I think today with the
proliferation of social media uh
smartphones and the access to the
internet I don't think we can get away
with the idea that oh the world has a
problem with us simply
because of our freedoms and liberties
this is utter this is just asinine I
think the world has a when you when you
commit atrocity after atrocity to a
people when we have a bad track record
here although I'm kind of Shifting
shifting gears here a bit uh we're
talking about Zionist now I'm talking
about what we're As Americans here what
we're doing across the globe or in the
world we have to kind of look at
ourselves and see well have we been good
stewards around the world yes we're
helping the poor we're helping the needy
but I think we we've done a we've we've
been the cause of a lot of Carn
in the world and I think it is time for
us as Americans to own up and to speak
to that and acknowledge perhaps maybe
why some parts of the world have a
problem with us and it's not because of
our you know Liberties or freedoms maybe
it's because what we've done to them
over the
decades what do you uh what do you think
is the reasoning for um you have someone
like uh Omar suan who's telling Jordan
Peterson to go to hell he's got him
worked he's pretty worked up I'm I'm
I why why would he I mean what would
there's what's the context now you would
think like to I am elated to see someone
like uh good move good move um that
we're moving beyond the whole
compassionate talk about love and mercy
I think that's good we got a lot of
compassion love in this we follow the
mercy the prophet of Mercy but we again
we don't want to overdo it I got where
we become the pushovers yes yeah so
kuros to uh to drar yes absolutely and
then you have over here um they're
pretty much a lot of people saying the
same thing so if Jordan Peterson is
sincere and he's reading some of these
comments and he's like there's got to be
something there like you know everyone
like from the the comments here are
pretty much saying they all bought he's
pretty much bought he s he pretty much
sold his soul you know what what what's
and I don't know where to begin when it
comes with Jordan Peterson because when
he when he the man is is a mountain of
knowledge a very knowledgeable person
and a very smart and intelligent person
no one can take that away from him and
this is not me saying hey let's bring
him to our next conference please this
is not what I'm getting at here but I've
noticed when he starts speaking about
issues out of his domain he really
starts to speak
nonsense whosoever speaks outside of his
own field of expertise will come with
very wild ludicrous and bizarre ideas
and unfortunately this is what's
happening with him so a bit of humility
on his
part it's a disgrace for a man of that
stature and that man of of of of
popularity really uh to to utter
nonsense like this uh Rabbi wise you had
you had I've had um Rabbi Shapiro on the
program and other Jews the
incompatibility between Judaism and
Zionism many Jews believe wrongly that
Zionism is either part of Judaism or is
compatible with Judaism or is even the
main part of Judaism all of those are
actually
false Zionism was created to negate
Judaism Zionism was created to replace
Judaism the differences between Zionism
and Judaism are vast they're vast and
profound the propaganda that the
zionists have churned out for the past
100 years have confused and conflated
Zionism and Judaism such that when the
average person walks down the street he
thinks that the state of Israel is the
Jewish State he thinks that Zionism is
Judaism and he doesn't know the
difference this group of Jews here are
students of the students of the late
satma Rabbi Rabel tidal bam who was the
greatest disseminator of the clarity
regarding the difference between Judaism
and Zionism Miko's friend of mine I
consider he's um he's someone out there
who's speaking the truth and I would
really recommend uh people who want to
know the truth to go look into some of
their work Isel really believe that the
IDF is the most moral army in the
world the Israeli media is playing this
shameful role of collaborating with the
occupation the government the Army the
secret Services don't want you to tell
and the consumers the readers and The
View don't want to hear and don't want
to know one day someone will ask what
happened here how come that this Society
is living this denial I try to whistle
in the darkness but I don't think it has
any influence on the contrary you see
that everything goes to the opposite
direction so what's the point I remember
I asked my father the same question one
day he said well I don't want them to be
able to say that they didn't know yeah
they cannot say they didn't know I mean
these are Norman Norman finlin okay I
mean what a man yeah do you know who
that is yes yes yeah may Allah guide him
to Islam he is
vocal he does not he does not he does
not know the art of sugarcoating may
Allah guide him to Islam right but I
mean no I mean imagine if we're pro if
we're we're chanting you know if you if
you see something like this this is not
what god- conscious people people who
are you know uh people no Muslims should
be chanting death to Moses or you know
even in Islam you have don't curse their
gods what do Allah
she'll this quip real
[Music]
quick what do you think when you see
that I mean again I don't I don't have
diabolical it it really really comes off
as being s satanic and diabolical I mean
it's not enough that you're oppressing a
people but you're finding joy and taking
pleasure in doing so we don't have our
way of life uh submission to the Creator
not the creation doesn't teach us to
hate a certain group of people because
they're a certain group of people you
had many Jews who actually even accepted
Islam live peacefully even if they don't
accept you know there isn't their life
and property everything they have they
they have certain rights in Islam that
now cannot even be transgressed you know
their right to worship their right to
you know uh live their lives according
even the church even the churches in
synagogues we as Muslims do not have the
right to desecrate those areas to vilify
those those places because Islam does
consider although although they're not
it's not a mid but Islam still consider
those that we still consider those
places to be sacred places they are not
to be touched when I had Rabbi weisson
and Miko billed and many of them
confirmed this that even before the
Zionist Zionist is more people are
atheists they really don't don't even
have much this this is more of an
atheist you know more in line with the
BTS people like this but I mean you have
good people like this like Miko pillet
and the the rabbi and they come out and
they talk about even the chief Rabbi at
the time because people don't know that
the the Christians are also being
oppressed there even Christians are I
was going to mention that yes they are
so what what's happening there is that
before this occupation you had
Christians Muslims and Jews they were
all together living in peace before 1948
uh they were living they were living
there were Jews there there were Muslims
and Christians there all living side by
side and they got along just fine yeah
they watching each other's kids right
there was like there was actual peace
yeah and then the chief Rabbi at that
time was saying no this is not do not do
this they were like I remember doing
this interview with the rabbi right and
uh Rabbi Shapiro he holds one of the the
greatest um conferences biggest
conferences they like I don't know
thousands thousands of rabbis coming
together who are really against this
whole this whole movement that's that's
you know causing this chaos you know
Allah in the Quran inan just just so
we're not painting everybody with the
same brush I think think these two
verses are very relevant uh in one verse
Allah
says uh so in of here it's of the people
of the book that if you entrust them
with a huge amount of wealth they will
readily and happily give it right back
to you but some of them if you entrust
them with just one dinar meaning a very
medical meager amount they will not give
it back to you until you stay running
after them right so clearly here the
Quran is not painting the Jews or the
Christians with one brush they're saying
that they're not the same in the sameah
Allah
says not the same of the people of the
book right and um again we we don't
approve you know it's very clear like I
opened up with the Hadi even in the
Quran you know
um human life is precious life uh we
talked about this uh before um many of
the you know the many of the the things
that Islam espouses and whatnot um let
me get into this next next tweet here
this is from my brother Zan smile the
Jenna he says the US government doesn't
have money to solve the plight of its
citizens but it has plenty of to support
the occupation and oppressor oppression
of Palestinians then we wonder why it's
so messed up there here are eight
billion reasons why and now you just
have here US President Biden approves
emergency milit aid package to Israel 8
billion and we have people laying on the
ground outside of hotels in the middle
of downtown in tents in many populated
cities cities Metropolis cities big
cities here in America you're you're
telling me our own citizens here and I
speak here as an American you're telling
me that they are not more deserving of
that
money you have people laying in tense
people after the pandemic losing their
homes families being destroyed because
of the the the economic stress that it
took that you know took a toll on them
but we have money just to send off left
and right mhm yeah this this is going to
anger a lot of people we the taxpayers
uh yeah and I wanted to really push that
point home that again this is not
something that
is where Muslims are just hate Jews you
know you have this professor here why
would just for the thinking person why
would this professor here uh Jewish
Professor David Warstein I've brought
this up many times because it's so
profound and Powerful right he in his uh
JC essay in the Jewish Chronicles he
said Islam saved the jury how's Islam
going to save you if it hates you you
know if it's uh Muslims are called to um
terrorize to hate you to you know uh
when when Muslims are saving you and
this is in essence to um you know the
time when they were being persecuted
Albania turkey Bosnia you have they were
running and being from pers fled for
persecution in France the Muslims at
that time were putting their lives on
life to save the Jewish people they were
forging documents for them uh you know
about it what are your thoughts on that
well that that's because Islam teaches
us to stand up for our
principles right um another verse that
comes to mind is where Allah
says Allah basically in the Quran says
that Allah does not uh uh keep you from
being good to those who did not fight
you for your religion or drive you out
of your homes these are the two
conditions right so being good extending
the helping hand right uh uh uh being
just towards them this is this is a
religious obligation even to the
atheist you might have some atheists who
are watching this like when when you see
someone who is in need of help although
even if they're an atheist they don't
believe in God right I as a Muslim it is
still my duty and obligation to help
help them if I can give and extend the
help in hand Islam clearly condemns I
just I've repeated it so many times the
killing of non-combatants uh innocent
men women and children this is very
clear what could Jordan Peterson if you
were going to have a message for him he
OB obviously had maybe still had some uh
who are not aware but now more people
are going to be aware of um uh his
stance and you know towards this whole
thing what do you think he could be
doing differently if you because you
admired some of his work I did also but
uh the direction he's going many people
are saying he just bought now and he's
really not on the on the line of Truth
what what what would you say he can he
can do differently Jordan Peterson If he
if he listens to this when Palestine is
free people like him are going to be
ashamed that they did this he's going to
be embarrassed that he did this I think
he's being extremely biased I think he's
being he's looking at things from from
one side and of course there there are
always two sides to to to a story but I
I I don't think he's had enough time to
kind of dig thoroughly and seriously and
diligently as to what in the world is
taking place on the other side and him
being who he is owes it to himself
expediently and urgently to take a look
as to what's happening on the other side
and then you feel free and you're
welcome to tweet whatever it is that you
feel but don't base your judgment off of
this one skewed one-sided skewed
nonsense do your research study the same
way you've done your studies for
everything else diligently and
thoroughly scrutinize what is taking
place in that part of the world before
tweeting this and I don't think anybody
with a heart anybody who um is a well-
Wisher for anybody to look at uh the
oppression that's happening I mean just
people being treated worse than animals
I mean it's it's it's it's a present day
apartate uh people get upset if you
mistreated an animal yeah let alone a
human being you know what I mean where's
human right where's human rights watch
where are they in all this yeah many
have uh many have condemned but the you
know the global Elites and people the
movers and shakers they're silent uh to
these oppressions that are happening and
um I think good-hearted Americans and
others out there I often recommended the
book of mik pillet some of his um his
because he's an AEL Jew his father was
the original signer of the Declaration
of Independence for Israel right so he
is really somebody who's putting his
neck on the line and look at some of
these other people like R RBI Weiss and
Puro and look what they're saying
they're Jewish when is Jewish or Israeli
and see the other side of the coin why
are they coming out and speaking on
behalf of the oppressed because they're
oppressed and there are people who don't
like to see oppression so with that said
um thank you very much for helping us uh
cover this briefly and we um we wish uh
that truth and peace and all the good
prevails because we really want to live
in peace with our neighbors and the rest
of mankind we uh indeed we do yeah yes
and we started with peace we with peace
peace be with
you thank you guys for tuning in don't
forget uh to go ahead and if you'd like
to see more learn more about the Islam
and Muslims I'll give you a free copy of
the Quran visit the Deans show.com get
your free copy there and don't miss any
future episodes by subscribing hit that
notification Bell and we'll see you next
time until then peace be with you Assam
alaykum have no doubt that it will be a
successful project inshallah I've had
the blessing of knowing brother Eddie
since he started the dean show and he's
one of the most sincere and most
dedicated people to the that I have ever
met so please do support the dean
[Music]
Center